uniformierte soldaten verkünden am
montag im staatsfernsehen eine
machtübernahme durch das militär in
burkina faso die regierung sei abgesetzt
und das parlament aufgelöst worden die
lage in dem westafrikanischen land ist
unübersichtlich aus sicherheitskreisen
hat es am montagmorgen geheißen der
präsident und weitere mitglieder seiner
regierung seien festgenommen und in eine
kaserne in der hauptstadt gebracht
worden aus regierungskreisen heißt es
jedoch später das sei gelungen den
staatschef am sonntagabend vor der
ankunft der soldaten aus seiner residenz
zu holen bereits am wochenende hatte es
heftige proteste gegen die regierung und
aufstände in mehreren kasernen des
landes gegeben die wieder im fernsehen
und auf facebook verbreiteten video
botschaft verkünden die soldaten dass
die grenzen geschlossen würden sie
versprechen eine rückkehr zur
verfassungsmäßigen ordnung innerhalb
einer angemessenen zeit
[Musik]